[Music]
what I think is the most competitive
category of the night Outstanding Drama
Series there are so many amazing
compelling shows in here better call
songs the crown The Handmaid's Tale
house of cards
stranger things this is us and West
world there is not a weak show in the
group because if you guys aren't
watching better call solving you're
seriously missing out it was hard for us
to predict yeah who could take this
category because it really does feel
like it's anybody's race but I will say
that I've been a big fan of this is us
from the beginning and if it wins it'll
be a network show hasn't won this
category since 2006 and that was 24 in
the last Network show to be nominated
was The Good Wife
in 2011 it would be a huge it's the only
Network show nominated in this category
and to go up against some huge cable and
premium cable TV series yeah and
streaming shows as well keep streaming
really taking at Netflix has three
horses in this race Hulu holding their
own with The Handmaid's Tale okay so I
feel like it should either be this is us
or stranger things but I think it will
be The Handmaid's Tale what do you guys
think we really want to know what's on
the comment section is also Westworld in
this rooms like so many good shows I'll
be happy if any of them I wish they feel
like if any of those one I wouldn't be
upset Golden Age TV guys Golden Age of
TV but you're going for him mates I'm
going for him eat stale go what this is
us okay we'll see I know I'm Rupert it's
so sweet
[Music]
you